gérard larcher bonjour bonjour merci de
nous recevoir dans votre permanence de
rambouillet oui je rappelle que vous
êtes le président les républicains du
sénat ce sénateur des yvelines alors on
l'a appris la semaine dernière la
disparition du troisième président élu
de la vème république valéry giscard
d'estaing une image un souvenir que vous
gardez de cet homme aux états unis
récent puisque je lui rendais visite
régulièrement et notre dernière
rencontre c'était en 2019
nous sommes téléphonés depuis une fois
elle portait sur la constitution
le projet de révision constitutionnelle
qui avait échoué d'emmanuel macron et
c'était aussi son attachement au
parlement je n'oublie pas que c'est à
valéry giscard d'estaing qu'on doit la
capacité de saisir le conseil
constitutionnel pour 60 députés ou 60
sénateurs ce qui est un droit formidable
notamment pour l'opposition
et puis c'est lui qui a mis en place les
questions au gouvernement
comme je les dis au sénat la semaine
dernière peut-être pour la plus grande
joie des ministres mais c'est en fait
quelqu'un qui a aussi renforcé le
parlement est tout le monde connaît
valéry giscard d'estaing
l'europe est un homme qui a fait évoluer
notre société sur la condition des
femmes sur l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse
c'est un homme qui a été profondément
moderne
alors justement vous parlez du recours
devant la cour constitutionnelle
ce texte pourrait faire l'objet d'un
recours devant le conseil
constitutionnel c'est la proposition de
loi de sécurité globale le texte a été
transmis au sénat le 24 novembre dernier
les sénateurs souhaitent à réécrire en
partie ce texte
on parle beaucoup de l'article 1 4 sur
la diffusion des images des forces de
l'ordre mais il ya aussi des
propositions sur les policiers
municipaux sur la formation dans les
métiers de sécurité quelle est votre
position par rapport à ce texte et
qu'est-ce que vous souhaiter pour
renforcer la sécurité des yvelines on a
notamment sur une proposition de loi 2
soixante cinq articles et traite aussi
bien comme vous l'avez dit de la police
municipale
mais ce qu'on appelle le continuum de
sécurité parce que on le voit bien face
à la montée des violences
la réponse de la sécurité est
essentielle dans un état de droit pour
les yvelinois on le voit dans les
parfums de coopération entre les polices
municipales la police nationale et la
gendarmerie améliorer encore ses
relations le fonctionnement c'est tout
simplement l'intérêt des citoyens
ce texte prévoit aussi l'articulation
avec la sécurité privée
et puis là aussi d'autres aspects dans
ce texte qui peuvent interroger
nous devons assurer aussi la protection
des policiers des gendarmes et des
sapeurs pompiers
cette protection là elle nécessite
qu'ils ne peuvent pas être fait pression
sur eux et je dois dire que en 15 ans
les agressions vis-à-vis des policiers
ont augmenté de 80 % vis-à-vis des
sapeurs pompiers en 10 ans de plus de
200%
il y a eu un rapport au sénat en 2019
sur ce sujet dochia de vraies
interrogations de vraies attentes
le sénat nous l'avons rappelé un peu
sèchement il n'est pas là pour ajuster
des textes il est là pour examiner dans
le cas du bicamérisme un texte qu'il a
nous vient de sembler nationale que nous
allons examiner en commission d'abord
des lois puis en séance plénière et le
texte qui sortira des travaux du sénat
il fera l'objet du dialogue avec
l'assemblée nationale on s'est un peu
énervé vous savez au début de la semaine
dernière du côté
du gouvernement et de l'assemblée
nationale ce qui m'a obligé mardi de la
semaine dernière
rappeler tout le monde tout simplement à
la lecture de la constitution qui porte
le même numéro
partick 24 le parlement vote la loi
alors un tout autre sujet d'actualité
c'est la crise sanitaire et ses
conséquences économiques
les très petites et moyennes entreprises
ont été très impacté alors tout dépend
aussi du secteur d'activité quelle est
la situation dans le département des
yvelines notamment dans les centres
villes dans les zones d'activités
d'abord cette crise sanitaire m'amène à
penser aux malades aux familles en deuil
à l'engagement des soignants qu'il soit
l'hôpital en ville à ceux qui
contribuent au quotidien
l'accompagnement de nos aînés je crois
qu'on ne doit pas l'oublier mais
naturellement il y à aussi la dimension
de crise économique de crise sociale
je suis frappé dans cette permanence par
le nombre de jeunes à la recherche d'un
stage à la recherche d'un petit boulot à
la recherche d'une alternance
on a donc des vrais sujets à résoudre
qui sont des sujets du quotidien
on me disait ici pour celles qui
assurent l'accueil permanent qu'en trois
mois il nous a été demandé plus
d'interventions pour trouver ce stage
cette alternance qu'en une année
c'est dire que c'est une vraie
préoccupation alors des entreprises dans
le département plus de 23000 déjà ont
fait appel au fonds d'indemnisation
il ya eu 30 prendre cinq mille demandes
d'activité partielle ma préoccupation va
bien sûr à toutes ces entreprises à
l'emploi et parfois aux conséquences de
cette crise qui conduira je le crains à
vers les pertes d'emplois mais il ya
aussi l'immédiateté que nous vivons en
ces temps de noël de coeur de ville de
coeur de village ou les commerces
dit non essentiel je ne sais pas ce que
très bien que ça veut dire ont été
fermés longuement dans une décision
qu'il aurait mieux fallu traiter
localement c'est ce que le cdh avait dit
à l'unanimité aujourd'hui il faut les
accompagner les soutenir et se dire que
la place de noël c'est d'abord au coeur
de votre ville au coeur de votre village
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'essentiel
me semble-t-il pour qu'on fasse noël et
que noël soit l'occasion en quelque
sorte d'apporter un peu de baume dans
les interrogations les angoisses je note
que beaucoup de commerçants et
d'artisans je le disais
et il y à peu avec le préfet et nous
échangions est il vraiment des temps
très très difficile pour certains
difficultés de l'immédiat vis-à-vis des
loyers des stocks énormes qui sont là
présents
il va falloir d accompagner au delà je
l'espère du processus de sortie
progressive du confinement
vous avez dit un impact social aussi 200
m
on fait un courrier au président de la
république le gouvernement donne une
réponse que le 1% du plan de relance
serait accordée aux quartiers
prioritaires parce que c'est là le sujet
c'est les quartiers prioritaires
quartier politique de la ville dans les
yvelines
il ya de nombreux quartiers de ce type
quelle votre garde là dessus j'ai reçu
la semaine dernière j'ai reçu les
représentants de ces maires parmi eux
catherine arenou le maire de chanteloup
les vignes la certitude d'avoir 1%
c'est bien le moins c'est tout
simplement ce qu'ils doivent recevoir
mais il ya d'autres sujets il notamment
il ya des chiffres qui montrent beaucoup
frappé le maire de roubaix qui étaient
là à porter témoignage qu'il avait
distribué en 3 mois + dead alimentaire
qu'en une année dans la ville de robert
le maire de grigny comme le maire jean
tout levin nous ont dit que près de 50%
des citoyens s'étaient désengagés de la
vie associative
faute de moyens
dans ces moments de blocage de la vie
collective et je dois dire qu'il faut
qu'on aille au delà
alors ils ont appelé ça le conseil des
solutions
c'est à dire la nécessité d'avoir une
agilité une capacité à répondre et
peut-être relire ce que jean-louis
borloo avait proposé au président de la
république qui l'a regardé d'une manière
un peu lointaine et peut-être un peu
condescendante ya je dois le dire
cette crise nous rappelle qu'il y a
beaucoup de cités et pas simplement les
cités dont on parle tout le temps car on
serait pas 200 maires que le maire de
cahors d'albi où d'ailleurs soit
signataire c'est qu'il y à bien des
quartiers dans lequel la crise a une
dimension tout à fait particulière avec
une fragilité humaine avec la tentation
que cette fragilité conduisent au repli
communautariste
est ce que en tant que président du
sénat représentants des collectivités
territoriales vous avez le sentiment que
le gouvernement le président a admis qu
en temps c'est mr en tous les cas c'est
ce que nous avons tenté de les faire
passer mardi dernier quand il a reçu à
ma demande et à la demande des
présidents de groupe
tous les présidents de groupes du sénat
nous avons parlé bien sûr de la crise
bien sûr de ce qui va être le plan
vaccination
bien sûr de la situation économique nous
avons beaucoup parlé de pauvreté car la
pauvreté c'est quelque chose et pas
simplement dans les 200 villes
signataires qui est une conséquence déjà
palpable et nous ne sommes pas en 2021
avec les interrogations que nous avons
sur la montée du chômage qui nous
inquiète mais la pauvreté
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup de jeunes qui faisait des
petits boulots pour beaucoup de gens qui
étaient à temps partiel et qu'il
complétait par d'autres activités
certaines officiels d'autres mois mais
la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui le
confinement
le blocage d'une partie de l'activité
et cette pauvreté là la crise n est a
aussi des conséquences sur la démocratie
de les prochaines les prochaines
échéances électorales
le report des départementales et des
régionales au mois de juin 2021 devrait
être officialisé un par le gouvernement
courant décembre
quelle est votre position quant à
l'organisation à la fois de la campagne
du scrutin d'abord d'où voteront la
semaine prochaine et sur le rapport de
jean louis devrais je crois que nous
allons dégager un accord pour que les
élections départementales et régionales
se tiennent au mois de juin qu'elle se
tienne dans un cadre qui devra être
adaptée campagne donc duré de campagne
comptes de campagne parce que la
démocratie c'est tout ça c'est le temps
de la campagne électorale c'est aussi le
contrôle de cette campagne notamment sur
les moyens financiers parce qu'une
démocratie c'est quelque chose qui est
équilibré entre les différents candidats
et mode
j'allais dire d'expression du vote
la procuration confirmé ce qui avait été
fait d'une manière peut-être encore plus
large
au nombre des élections municipales du
printemps question des salles nous
aurons des faits une élection synchrone
départementales et régionales
vous n'êtes pas d'ailleurs que ce soit
un sas tiennent le même jour c'est un
vote qui a déjà eu lieu et il faut le
confirmer
ça vous change pas les règles du jeu
tout le temps un je crois qu'en
démocratie c'est aussi des règles du jeu
claires connu l avance et dans lequel on
évolue pas ouvrait j'allais dire des
humeurs ou des calculs politiques et il
ya des endroits où c'est difficile de
faire tenir dans une pièce comme celle
ci parce qu'il ya des mérites cette
taille là le deux scrutins donc
réflexion autour des conditions
d'organisation des bureaux de vote
et puis bien sûr faut-il ou non voter
par correspondance
la semaine prochaine la commission des
lois du sénat rendra son rapport
son rapport et son avis sur toutes ces
questions soulevées par le scrutin et
notamment la question du vote par
correspondance avec ça les dires deux
exigences
il faut que ce soit votre sincère il
faut qu'ils soient fiables et il faut
techniquement à cause du deuxième tour
qui soit réalisable parce que régionales
ça veut dire le mardi soir en cas de
fusion de listes est ce qu'on est
capable d'éditer la profession de foi la
nouvelle liste de l'adresser à des
lecteurs et électeurs aient le temps de
voter voilà des sujets sincérité du
scrutin
mais aussi fiabilité de la méthode votre
regard sur les enjeux de ces deux
scrutins alors au niveau 1 région
ile-de-france et département des idéaux
du département des yvelines
je pense que j j zay conforter la
majorité départementale
elle peut pas être plus conforté qu'elle
n'ait puisque tous les cantons
j'allais dire sont représentés par des
conseillers départementaux qui
appartient avec une diversité politique
certaine mais à la majorité
départementale
ça doit être l'occasion aussi dans un
certain nombre de cas de renouvellement
de candidats il y à un certain nombre de
candidats qui ont dit qu'il se
représenterait pas et l'enjeu c'est la
place et le rôle du département et je
dois dire que quand ces temps où par
exemple vallée de seine les questions
économiques et sociales restent
extrêmement forte
vous voyez bien que l'industrie
automobile mais aussi d'autres activités
industrielles connaissent des
difficultés
en ces temps où il nous faut conforter
des politiques sociales
nous avons besoin d'un département
active présent naturellement l'élection
régionale
est une élection est essentielle
beaucoup a été fait je dois le dire sous
la présidence de valéry pécresse
je pense au quotidien même s'il reste
encore beaucoup à faire sur les
transports je pense à la question
environnementale la question économique
mais aussi on l'a vu dans la crise sans
les mères sans le conseil départemental
sans le conseil régional
je vais pas bien certains je porte à
masquer cet instant qu'on ait pu sortir
de la première crise de la même manière
ils ont démontré au fond qu'ils étaient
au service des citoyens et du quotidien
en proximité car le sujet de la
proximité c'est un sujet essentiel dans
notre démocratie
vous allez être président du comité de
soutien de valérie pécresse pendant sept
ans mais quel rôle vous allez jouer en
l2 la bourde et je l'avais déjà été la
fois dernière
mon rôle c'est d'abord dans ma
responsabilité de deux sénateurs
d'indiquer que la proche que valérie
pécresse a du territoire francilien est
une approche qui correspond dans la
proximité ça n'est pas rien d'être dans
la proximité avec plus de 12 millions
d'habitants
elle prend en compte cette formidable
région cette région capitale qui a une
responsabilité nationale majeure si je
prends un exemple en matière
environnementale elle a beaucoup plus
fait que tous ceux qui se proclament et
des environnementalistes et donc dégagé
avec elle autour d'elle c'est le rôle
d'un président de comité de soutien ça
veut dire quelques éléments du projet
qui doivent être des projets partagés
nous ne devons pas oublier que l'île de
france est aussi un département comme la
seine saint denis avec d'immenses
difficultés et bien les réponses que
nous devons apporter
elles doivent s'adapter à chacun des
territoires mais elles doivent être une
marque commune celle de notre région
celle de ses responsabilités avec
notamment la dimension économique est
derrière la crise économique
la région sera un acteur majeur et si le
plan de relance réussie il ne réussira
qu'à une condition qu'ils soient des
concentrés au niveau de la région au
niveau département et au niveau des
communes
un dernier mot pour conclure on sait que
vous suivez ma vérité grèce depuis
plusieurs années maintenant est ce que
ces régionales pour elle ça représente
un tremplin peut-être pour les élections
présidentielles de la mine c'est d'abord
un tremplin pour la région ile-de-france
donc cédé leur jeu c'est valérie
pécresse encore j'allais dire à la tête
de l'ile-de-france pour les six années
qui viennent
ça m'apparaît tout à fait tout à fait
essentiel ensuite pécresse c'est une
femme politique nationale c'est le sujet
il faudra que se dégage un candidat dans
les familles du centre de la droite
républicaine chez les gaullistes un ou
une candidate
c'est ce à quoi je travaille pour gagner
que j'allais dire le mot mort du cac
seul candidat parce que je pense que
nous avons une responsabilité centre et
la droite c'est d'offrir une alternative
à emmanuel macron parce que si la seule
alternative c'est emmanuel macron marine
le pen ou emmanuel macron jean luc
mélenchon je pense que ça n'est pas
d'alternative
ce que je souhaite après qu'il y ait un
débat et bien entre emmanuel macron et
un candidat ou une candidate que nous
soutiendrons c'est tout simplement une
démocratie qui fonctionne avant deux
compères vous dites que vous travaillez
dessus de quelle manière je suis en
train de voir tout où tous les candidats
ou les candidats potentiels de réfléchir
à ce qui pourrait être une méthode de
départage me laissez moi là un peu de
tout on en parlera au printemps merci
gérard a fait président et les
républicains du sénat et sénateur des
yvelines